speaking of diet
if we could just linger on that uh that
topic a little bit
we already talked about your your blog
post of i
i fired myself i fired brian the the
evening
brian who is uh too willing to uh
not not making good decisions for the
long-term well-being and happiness
of the entirety of the organism uh
basically you were like pigging out at
night and but it's
interesting because i do this i do the
same
in fact i often eat one meal a day
and uh like i have been this this week
actually especially when i travel
and it's it's funny that uh
it never occurred to me to just
basically look at the fact that i'm
able to be much smarter about my eating
decisions in the morning in the
afternoon than i am at night
so if i eat one meal a day why not eat
that one meal a day
in the morning like i'm not
it never occurred to me this
revolutionary yeah
until until you've uh you've outlined
that so maybe
can you give some details and what this
is just you
this is one person brian arrives at a
particular
thing that they do but it's fascinating
uh to kind of
look at this one particular case study
so what works for you
diet-wise what what's your actual diet
what do you eat
how often do you eat my current protocol
is
basically the the result of thousands of
experiments
and decision making so i've i do this
every 90 days i do the tests
i do the cycle throughs then i measure
again and then
i'm measuring all the time and so what i
i of course i'm
optimizing for my biomarkers i want
perfect cholesterol and i want perfect
blood glucose levels and perfect dna
methylation
you know processes
i also want perfect sleep and so for
example
recently the past two weeks my resting
heart rate
has been a 42 when i sleep and when my
resting heart rate's at 42
my hrv is at its highest and i wake up
in the morning
feeling more energized than any other
configuration
and so i know from all these processes
that eating at roughly 8 30 in the
morning
right after i work out on an empty
stomach creates enough
distance between that completed eating
and bedtime where
i have no almost no digestion processes
going on
in my body therefore my resting heart
rate goes very low
and when my heart rate is very low i
sleep with high quality and so basically
i've been trying to optimize
the entirety of what i eat to my sleep
quality
and my sleep quality then of course
feeds into my willpower so it creates
this
virtuous cycle and so what at 8 30 what
i do is i eat
what i call super veggie which is it's a
pudding
of 250 grams of broccoli 150 grams of
cauliflower and a whole bunch of other
vegetables
that i eat uh what i call nutty pudding
which is make the pudding itself like
red like veg like
the what you call it like a veggie mix
whatever
thing is that like a blender nice but
yeah the pasta can be made in a high
speed blender but basically i eat the
same thing
every day veggie bowl uh as a in the
form of pudding
and then a bowl in the form of nuts
and then i have vegan vegan yes vegan
and so that's fat and that's like uh
there's fat and carbs
and excessive protein and so on
everything tastes good
i'd love it i i love it so much i dream
about it
yeah that's awesome this is uh and then
i have a third dish which is
it changes every day uh today it was
kale and spinach and sweet potato
and then i take about 20 supplements
that hopefully make
constitute a perfect nutritional profile
so what i'm trying to do is
create the perfect diet for my body
every single day
where sleep is part of the optimization
that's right you're like one of the
things you're really tracking
me can you well i have a million
questions but 20 supplements like what
kind they're
like would you say are essential because
i only take i only take uh
athletic athletic greens.com
that's like the multivitamin essentially
that's like the lazy man you know like
like if you don't actually want to think
about that's what you take and then
uh
fish oil and that's it that's all i take
yeah you know alfred
north whitehead said advan uh
civilization
advances as it extends the number of
important operations it can do
without thinking about them yes and so
my objective on this is i want an
algorithm for perfect health that i
never have to think about
and that i want that system to be
scalable to anybody so that they don't
have to think about it
and right now it's expensive for me to
do it it's time consuming for me to do
it and i have
infrastructure to do it but the future
of being human
is not going to the grocery store and
deciding what to eat
it's also not reading scientific papers
trying to decide this thing or that
thing
it's all n of one so it's the it's
devices on the outside and inside your
body
assessing real time what your body needs
and then creating closed loop systems
for that to happen
yeah so right now you're doing the data
collection
and you're being the scientist it'd be
much better if you're doing just that if
you just did the data collect or it was
being essentially done for you and you
can
outsource that to another scientist
that's doing the n1 study of you
that's right because every time i spend
time thinking about this or executing
spending time i'm spending less time
thinking about yeah
building kernel or or the future of
being human and so it's
we just all have this the budget of
our capacity on an everyday basis and
we will scaffold our way up out of this
and so yeah hopefully that what i'm
doing is really it serves as a model
uh that others can also you build that's
why i wrote about it is hopefully people
can take it and improve upon it
i hold nothing sacred i change my diet
almost every day
based upon some new test results or
science or something like that but
can you maybe elaborate on the sleep
thing why is sleep so important
and why i presumably if like
what does good sleep mean to you
i think sleep is a contender for
being the most powerful
health intervention in existence
it's a contender i mean it's uh it's
magical what it does if you're well
rested and what your body
can do and i mean for example i know
when
when i eat close to my bedtime and i've
done a systematic study
for years uh looking at like 15 minute
increments on time of day and where i
eat my last meal
my willpower is directly correlated to
my to the amount of deep sleep i get
so my ability to not binge eat at night
when rascal brian's out and about
is based upon how much deep sleep i got
the night before yeah and so
there's some there's a lot to that yeah
and so i just i've seen it
manifest itself and so the i think
the way i summarize this is in society
we've had this myth
of we tell stories for example of
entrepreneurship
where this person was so amazing they
stayed at the office for three days and
slept under their desk
and we say wow that's amazing there's
that's amazing
and now i think we're headed towards a
state where we say
that's primitive and really not a good
idea
on every level and so
the new mythology is going to be the
exact opposite
yeah by the way just to sort of maybe
push back a little bit on that idea
uh did you sleep under your desk
collects
well yeah a lot i'm not a big believer
in that actually i'm a big believer in
in chaos and not giving and like giving
it to your passion
and sometimes doing things that are out
of the ordinary that are
like not trying to optimize health for
certain periods of time
in uh in lieu of your passions
is a signal to yourself that you're
throwing everything away so
i think what you're referring to is
how to have good performance for
prolonged periods of time
i think there's there's moments in life
when you need to throw all of that away
all the plans away all the structural
ways so the
i i don't this i'm not sure
i have an eloquent way of describing
exactly what i'm talking about but
it all depends on different people on
people people are different
but there's a danger of over
optimization
to where you don't just give in to the
madness
of the way your brain flows
i mean to push back on my pushback is
like
it's nice to have like where the k
where the foundations
of your brain are not messed with so you
have a fixed foundation
where the diet is fixed where the sleep
is fixed and that all that is optimal
and the chaos happens in the space of
ideas as opposed to the space of biology
but you know i i'm not sure if there's a
great
uh that requires real discipline and
forming habits
there's some aspect to which some of the
the best
uh days and weeks of my life have been
yeah sleeping under a desk kind of thing
and i don't i'm not too willing
to let go of things that empirically
worked for things that
work in theory and so i'm i'm
again i'm absolutely with you on sleep
also i'm with you on sleep conceptually
but
i'm also very humbled to understand that
for different people
good sleep means different things i'm
very hesitant
to trust science on sleep i think you
should
also be a scholar of your own body again
experiment of n of one
i'm not so sure that
a full night's sleep is great for me
there is something about that power nap
that i just have not fully studied yet
but that nap is something special yeah
i'm not sure i found the optimal thing
yeah um
so like there's a lot to be explored to
what is exactly optimal
amount of sleep optimal kind of sleep
combined with diet and all those cousins
i mean that all maps to sort of data at
least the truth exactly what all
everything you're referring to
here's a data point for your
consideration yes
the progress in biology over the past
say decade has been stunning yes and
it now appears as if we will be able to
replace our organs
xerox transplantation and so
we probably have a path to replace and
regenerate
every organ of your body except for your
brain
you can you can lose your hand and your
arm and a leg you can have an artificial
heart
you can't operate without your brain and
so when
you make that trade-off decision of
whether you're going to sleep under the
desk or not and go all out
for a four-day marathon
right there's a there's a cost-benefit
trade-off of what's going on what's
happening to your brain in that
situation
we don't know the consequences of modern
day life on our brain
we don't it's the most valuable organ
in our existence and we don't know
what's going on if we in in how we're
treating it today with
stress and with sleep and with dietary
and to me then if you say
that you're trying to you're you're
trying to optimize life for whatever
things you're trying to do the game
is soon with the progress and anti-aging
and biology the game is very soon going
to become different than what it is
right now
uh with organ rejuvenation organ
replacement and
i'm i would conjecture that
we will value the health status of our
brain
above all things yeah no absolutely
everything's you're saying is true but
i we die we died pretty quickly
life is short and
i'm one of those people that uh
i would rather die in battle than uh
then
stay safe at home it's like
you you look at kind of there's a lot of
things that you can reasonably say these
are this is the smart thing to do
that can prevent you that becomes
conservative that can prevent you from
fully embracing life
i think ultimately you can be very
intelligent and data driven
and also embrace life but i er on the
side of embracing life
it's very it takes a very skillful
person
to not sort of that hovering parent that
says no you know what
there's a three percent chance that if
you go out
if you go all by yourself and play
you're going to die
get run over by a car come to a slow or
a sudden
end and uh
i'm more a supporter of just go out
there if you die you die
and that's a you it's a balance you have
to strike
i think long there's a balance of
striking long-term optimization
and uh short-term
freedom for me for a programmer
for a programming mind i tend to over
optimize and i'm
very cautious and afraid of that to not
over optimize and thereby be overly
cautious suboptimally cautious about
everything i do and that's the ultimate
thing i'm trying to optimize for it's
funny you said like sleep and all those
kinds of things
i tend to think this is uh you're being
more precise
than i am but i think i tend to want to
minimize stress
which everything comes into that from
your sleep and all those kinds of things
but
i worry that whenever i'm trying to be
too strict with myself
then the stress goes up when i don't
follow the strictness
and so you have to kind of it's a weird
it's a
there's so many variables in an
objective function as it's hard to get
right
and sort of not giving a damn about
sleep and not giving a damn
diet is a good thing to inject in there
every once in a while
for somebody who's trying to optimize
everything that's but that's me just
trying to uh
like it's exactly like you said you're
just a scientist i'm a scientist of
myself you're a scientist of yourself
it'd be nice if somebody else was doing
it and had much better data
than uh because i don't trust my
conscious mind and i pigged out last
night at some brisket
in la that uh i regret deeply it's still
uh there's no point to anything i just
said but
what what is the nature of your regret
on the brisket is it do you wish you
hadn't
eaten it entirely is it that you wish
you hadn't eaten as much as you did
is it that
i think uh well the most regret i mean
if we
want to be specific i drank
way too much uh like diet soda my
biggest regret is like having drank so
much diet soda
that's the thing that really was the
problem i had trouble sleeping because
of that
because i was like programming and i was
editing and so i stayed up late at night
and then i had to get up to to go pee a
few times and it was just a mess
of the night it was well it's not really
a mess but
like it's so many it's like the little
things i know if i just
eat i i drink a little bit of water and
that's it and
there's a certain all of us have perfect
days
that we know diet wise and so on that's
good to follow you feel good
i know what it takes for me to do that i
didn't fully do that
and thereby because there's there's an
uh avalanche effect
where the other sources of stress all
the other to do items i have
pile on my failure to execute on some
basic things that i know make me feel
good and all that combines
to uh you know to create to create a
mess of a day
but some of that chaos you know you have
to be okay with it but some of it i wish
was uh
was a little bit more optimal and your
ideas about
eating in the morning are quite
interesting as an experiment to try yeah
can you
elaborate are you eating once a day
yes in the morning and that's it
can you maybe speak to how that
you spoke it's funny you spoke about the
metrics of sleep
but you're also you know and you
run a business you're incredibly
intelligent you have to
most of your happiness and success
relies on you
thinking clearly so how does that affect
your mind
and your body in terms of performance so
not just sleep but actual like mental
performance
as you were explaining your objective
function of for example in the criteria
you are
including you like certain neurochemical
states like you
like feeling like you're living life
that life has enjoyment
that sometimes you want to disregard
certain rules to
have a moment of passion of focus
there's this architecture of
the way lex is which makes you happy as
a story you tell
as something you kind of experience
maybe the experience is a bit more
complicated but it's in this idea you
have this is a version of you
and the reason why i maintain the
schedule i do
is i've chosen a game to say i would
like to live a life
where i care more about what
intelligent what people
who live in 2000 the year 2 500
think of me than i do today
that's the game i'm trying to play and
so therefore
the only thing i really care about on
this optimization
is trying to see past myself
past my limitations using xero's
principle thinking
pull myself out of this contextual mesh
we're in right now and say
what will matter a hundred years from
now and 200 years from now what are the
big things really going on that are
defining reality
and i find that if i
were to hang out with diet soda lex
and diet soda brian were to play along
with that and my deep sleep were to get
crushed as a result my mind would not be
on what matters
in 100 years or 200 or 300 years i would
be irritable
i would be you know i'd be in a
different state and so
it's just gameplay selection it's what
you and i have chosen to think about
it's what we've chosen to
work on and this is why i'm saying that
no generation
of humans have ever been afforded the
opportunity to look
at their lifespan and contemplate
that they will have the possibility of
experiencing
an evolved form of consciousness that is
unidentifiable that would fall in a
zeroth category
of potential that to me is the most
exciting thing in existence and i would
not trade
any momentary neurochemical state
right now in exchange for that i would
i'd be willing to deprive myself of all
momentary joy
in the pursuit of that goal because
that's what makes me happy
that's brilliant but i'm uh i'm a bit
i just looked it up
i just looked up braveheart speech and
william wallace but
i know you've seen it fighting you may
die run and you'll live
at least a while and dying in your beds
many years from now
would you be willing to trade all the
days from this day to that
for one chance just one chance picture
of mel gibson saying this
to come back here and tell our enemies
that they may take our lives
with growing excitement but they'll
never take our freedom
i get excited every time i see that in
the movie but that's kind of how i
approached life uh and
do you think they were treated in their
sleep i did we're not tracking their
sleep and they ate way too much brisket
and they were fat
unhealthy died early and uh
were primitive but uh there's some
there's something in my eight brain
that's attracted to that
even though most of my life is fully
aligned
with the way you see yourself and part
of it is for comedy of course but part
of it is like
i'm almost afraid of uh over
optimization really what you're saying
though
if we're looking at this let's say from
a first principal's perspective
when you read those words they conjure
up certain life experiences but you're
basically saying i experience a certain
neurotransmitter state when these things
are in action
yeah that's all you're saying so whether
it's that or something else you're just
saying
you have a selection for how your state
for your body
and so if you as an engineer of
consciousness
that should just be engineerable yeah
and that's just
triggering certain chemical reactions
and so whether
so it doesn't mean they have to be
mutually exclusive you can have that and
experience that and also
not sacrifice long-term health and i
think that's the potential of where
we're going is
we don't have we don't have to assume
they are trade-offs that must be had
absolutely and so i guess for my
particular brain
it's useful to have the outlier
experiences
that also come along with the uh
illusion of free will where i chose
those
races that make me feel like it's
freedom listen
going to texas made me realize i spent
so i was i still
am but i lived at cambridge at mit
and i never felt like home there i felt
like home
in the space of ideas with the
colleagues like when i was actually
discussing ideas but
there is something about the constraints
the
how cautious people are how much they
valued also kind of uh
material success career success
when i showed up to texas it felt like
i belonged that was very interesting but
that's my
neurochemistry whatever the hell that is
whatever whatever
maybe probably is rooted to the fact
that grew up in the soviet union it was
so
such a constrained system that you'd
really deeply value freedom and you've
you always want to escape the demand and
the control of centralized systems i
don't know what it is
but that's but at the same time i love
strictness
i love the dogmatic authoritarianism of
diet
of like the same habit exactly the habit
you have i think that's actually when
bodies perform
optimally my body performs optimally so
balancing those two
i think if i have the data every once in
a while party with some wild people but
most of the time eat once a day
perhaps in the morning i'm gonna try
that it might be very interesting
but i'd rather i'd rather not try it i'd
rather have the data that
tells me to do it but in general you're
able to
eating once a day think deeply about
stuff
like this concern that people have is
like
you know what does your energy wane all
those kinds of things
do you find that it's especially because
um
it's unique it's vegan as well so you
find that you're able to have a clear
mind
a focus and just physically and mentally
throughout
yeah i find like my personal experience
in
thinking about hard things
is like oftentimes i feel like i'm
i'm looking through a telescope and like
i'm aligning two or three telescopes and
you kind of have to
close one eye and move it back and forth
a little bit and just find
just the right alignment and you find
just a sneak peek at the thing you're
trying to find but it's fleeting if you
move just one little bit it's gone yeah
and oftentimes
what i feel like are the hot the ideas i
value the most
are like that they're so fragile and
fleeting
and slippery and elusive and
it requires a sensitivity
to thinking and a sensitivity to
maneuver through these things
if i
concede to a world where i'm on my phone
texting i'm also on social media i'm
also doing 15
things at the same time because i'm
running the company and i'm also feeling
terrible from the last night
it all just comes crashing down and the
quality of my thoughts
goes to a zero i'm just a i'm a
functional person
to respond to basic level things but i
don't feel like i
am doing anything interesting
i think that's a good word sensitivity
because that's when you
that's that's what uh thinking deeply
feels like is you're sensitive to the
fragile thoughts
and you're right all those other
distractions kind of dull
your ability to be sensitive to the the
fragile thoughts
it's a really good word
you